video games and social media appeared at
the exact same moment
so like all this weird video game murder
fantasy i mean you kill stuff in video
games that's most video games is you
kill things it's almost all violent and
acceptable you're the good guy i gotta
stop you i gotta stop you the goose game
except game dude just the goose game
that game is
amazing even in pac-man you're eating
ghosts yeah no right you'll kill me
think about pac-man no no video games
are all about the seven deadly sins man
in pac-man is just gluttony you're your
goal is to just keep
eating eating and like what's the story
of pac-man are the
like the ghosts being like dude you're
eating all our food and he goes
give me drugs and so now
social media comes out and people are
like brainwashed to kill and destroy
probably from video games
pac-man is actually sexist the creator
of pac-man so no it's actually funny the
creator of pac-man said the reason that
he wanted to create a video game that
would cater towards females and he said
women are always eating so like
i'm not i was actually raised and it
worked man but
but everyone loves pac-man though too
it's not and they made miss pacquiao i
had miss pac-man on the atari
she had a bow in her head just pac-man
with a bow and here's the difference
between pac-man and miss pac-man
has a bow it's a much faster game is it
yeah it's significantly faster
and all stuck on the wall with your
mouth open keep well and the maps the
maps actually change the original
pac-man was the exact same map over and
over and over again and if you knew the
right path to take you could just keep
doing that you would never get caught
once
whereas with miss pac-man they actually
chained it up oh yeah i actually missed
pac-man it might be more fun
it is really fun so but why is it that
uh
games typically involve combat you know
i thought about this it's like
our destructive animal nature maybe
that's my guess
maybe it's just maybe it's well maybe
maybe it's because conflict
conflict resolution of some sort
overcoming yeah
experiencing resistance makes you feel
like there's two games that i play right
now
spelunky ii and skater xl and skater xl
is just absolutely not violent to any
capacity it's literally just a skate
simulator so soothing yeah it's soothing
it's fun i might
make the dude do like a 360 flip mute
900. it's just great i just like oh man
look at this guy's flying through
spelunky though is like i wouldn't call
it violent because they're little sprite
creatures like there's just like little
you know mario there's some soup that's
like some of that game is just like
really
just like the adorable little sprites
and other stuff and it's like super dark
and violent like
so skyrim is fun but i want to play a
game like an elder scrolls game
where they can uh artificially generate
in real time
reactions from the npcs from the
non-player characters so like you'll
walk into a village
and they'll be like what are you doing
and you'll pull your sword out why are
you drawing your sword
don't point a thing at me oh he's gonna
swing it like they can actually just say
things and react in their own weird
randomized ways
i think quantum computing is gonna help
a lot i just can't wait till they make
joe biden simulator for oculus
video games just appealing to the male
fantasy
no malarkey joe as i say what is that
fantasy
simulator did you guys do you guys see
the andrew yang presidential fighting
game
no it came out a while ago it was really
really funny i don't know whatever
happened to it
but it was like during the primary and
the storyline was that you were andrew
yang and
he throws money it's a super move and
like he fights donald trump
it was really really good yeah elizabeth
warren it was it was
i was really impressed because the dude
made it was a yang supporter but it was
very very offensive what elizabeth
warren would do
her super move was to summon a charging
buffalo oh my god
and she would literally do like the wawa
you know
thing when she would throw stuff and she
had like native american headdress and
stuff but here's the difference
wow but no but that's the difference
like that that joke is not making fun of
native americans it is making fun of her
for being racist and trying to
appropriate their culture
did you see the dna the dnc had around
the native the indigenous caucus or
whatever
yeah i did a cartoon about that yeah
amazing i did a cartoon with that
the fact that they actually just the
total lack of self-awareness
dude these people have lost it i was
reading they never have it
they i mean no look have you guys my
friends
my friends please yes did you see that
they're doing a new movie about covid
called songbird
oh i heard talking i heard you talking
about this earlier
covered 23 physically painful it's
mutated the mortality rate is 50 percent
and it's like oh my god it's so bad but
hold on hold on
i bring this up for a reason it brings
up for reason i just watched the craft
legacy the other night
all right you guys know the movie the
craft no no it's where these these high
school girls are witches they're witches
yeah
i do remember that i never saw it dude
jordan peterson is the villain of the
craft legacy i'm not even
i'm not even kidding i'm not even
kidding it's not a big cauldron it's a
so the bad guy in the craft legacy and i
don't want to spoil too much
is is a it's like how how the woke view
jordan peterson
your powers are no match for me your
powers i'll summon all of my archetypes
dragon come from the underworld and then
it goes and attacks the witches
so so hold on i might spoil a bit so
spoiler alert for those that want to
watch
the craft legacy yeah no the reason i
bring this up is that
there's a flipping happening like so
listen man
uh i play music i i you know do creative
things i skateboard
and i am not aligned with the left right
now and there are a bunch of pro
skateboarders who are voting for trump i
talk to all the time
they like they want to send me gear and
i'm like how is it that like we have
ended up
on the trump side of this thing so when
you have
a like have you ever seen those
christian movies
you know what i mean like they're
conservative christians that's not dead
too
the greatest time
like conservatives try making movies and
they don't do a good job of it yeah
that's true but i think it's changing
i think the creatives the fun the
thinkers the imagine the the imagineers
they're not on the left anymore because
you're not allowed dude to conform
so listen in this movie the craft legacy
there's no movie
none whatsoever it is literally just a
series of scenes
where woke girls go around talking about
wokeness
nice and i oh man i'm you know i'm just
not spoiled
tim are they the granddaughters of the
witches we couldn't burn
oh my god
without spoiling too much and by telling
you the villain was jordan peterson
you've already so uh david cleaning
their room
david duchovny plays a guy and i've
already spoiled by saying by telling you
this do it because like it's
like a big reveal at the end or whatever
it's so dumb but he
he's got he writes a bunch of books
about masculinity
and he literally refers to them as like
disrupting order
oh my god i'm like dude they're they're
trying to create
take this like idea of jordan peterson
and make a villain out of it when did
they make this film
it just came out oh this just came out
it was intentionally jordan peterson
so i that was their villain in their
witch movie of course it was but it's
but it's it's not it's not your jordan
peterson
yeah it's a jordan peterson who would be
like masculinity is order
ah yeah
that's how i see him dude dude you got
to see it it is
it is god's not dead too is better than
this whoa cool like
listen listen well god god that's not
saying much tim hold on
i've never seen god's not dead either
i'm just ripping out
i'm horrible it could be a perfectly
decent movie
no no way i've so we had uh uh i've seen
these shows there was one i used to
watch these shows
what was it called psycho cop two psycho
comprehensive no no we
we we had a christian channel in chicago
i can't it's a long time ago yeah
there's a couple i think
but they had cartoons that were actually
decent they were rather poorly produced
but still
entertaining did you ever watch gerbert
gerbert do you remember gerber is like a
christian cartoon all right
that wasn't a cartoon it's like a puppet
thing that's amazing
if you saw it on this channel there's a
couple weeks i remember watching these
shows i can't remember what it was but
it was like a cartoon
that was moderately well produced but
nowhere near on par of like batman
animated series and stuff
and it was entertaining and then i
watched the craft and i'm like
this is the worst movie i've ever seen
in my life and i've seen birds of prey
i've seen cats it's heavy-handed i saw i
saw cats
i saw cats in theater why did you do
that because the song memory is a really
good song
and so is mr mistoffelees and they
ruined both
and that's when i was like haromf
turned against the media it was on that
day
hollywood everybody knows that mr
mistoffelees and memory are great songs
not everyone knows that because i didn't
aware i don't even know my memories your
memory was just repressed because the
greatness of the song
like when you were in my subconscious
when you saw it
the original versions by andrew lloyd
webber are excellent mm-hmm
i believe andrew was phenomenal and in
the movie
it was just like when the woman was
singing memory
she's crying so it's like and they're
snot pouring out of her nose and i'm
like this is
awful they wanted to make it as gross
now hold on they're like how do we make
the most unpleasant looking film the
craft legacy is worse than that
the craft legacy is you're making hey
you want to watch
right it's a woke movie i don't think i
can see it where the only thing is oh i
want to spoil so much no no
dude it's funny it's funny though i want
to say it
it's funny there's so much funny stuff
i'm gonna tell you what i'm gonna say i
don't know because the audience might
not appreciate it sometimes
the audience might want to watch the
jordan peterson is hitler film about
witches
that's amazing he's like he's got dude
he's he's having like
uh i'm spoiling the movie it's like
the best thing ever i bloody don't like
women that's right
yeah so hold on i'm i i'm probably being
a bit
hyperbolic by saying the villain is
jordan peterson oh well now i feel
but in in the movie when he says
that like you've just like we are order
or something i was like
dude that's jordan peterson has said
like masculinity is order
and femininity is chaos or whatever and
he's talking about what archetypes or
something
yeah i'm spoiling it i'm gonna i'm gonna
do it and you can spoil okay all right
so they break it down did the chat
consider that maybe i want to watch
no they break his feelings they break
into a guy's house
and they turn him woke with magic
yeah they they take his bong and they
take a used condom
they put them together and they put a
bunch of magic items in it
and then they wipe it on his pillow and
the next day
he's woke that's like a horrible and
he's disgusting thing to do he goes
you would think of that who would think
of that and put it in a movie
what was that like a condom
and it poked a hole in it so we didn't
know there was a condom in it but no no
no
no no i don't know and then like for
some reason they have the power to
freeze time
it just like happens randomly and
they're like kind of present
so this is the weirdest thing she is
like walking through the hall this is in
the trailer so it's not spoiling too
much
and the guy who they turn woke he's
mocking her and he puts his hands on her
shoulders
and then she like puts her hand up and
he goes flying 20 feet through the air
so then she gets put attention for
hitting him and i'm like
what person in their right mind would
see a guy go flying 20 feet like that
little girl must have struck him
yeah it'd be like whoa what the what's
going on anyway so when she goes home
her new stepdad who is jordan peterson
he's like
it's not it's it's it's an evil version
it's like probably it's how they view
him
he writes books about masculinity and he
has seminars about masculinity
and she's and he goes what he's like
he's very calm he goes
what's this i heard that you hit you
know timmy in school
and she goes i was defending myself and
he goes don't speak when i'm speaking to
you
i have a zero tolerance policy for
violence in this house
i'm disappointed and he walks away and
that was it and she goes
and she's like freaking out and i'm like
wait wait hold on that's reasonable
that's all he did that's all he said i'm
disappointed in you sounds like the
villain
i thought if he was going to be a
villain to smack her across the face and
be like i am the man of this house no he
was just like i have a zero tolerance
probably for violence
policy for violence and i am
disappointed and he walks off and she
was like what a grave injustice
so later on there's uh like
okay man i don't want to spoil too much
but but but uh there's there's a moment
where
a character dies and her new step family
there's like a ring of people a ring of
men and and they're all snapping their
fingers for some reason going like this
it's a weird that's what like men do
right do you guys want to go to the
jordan peterson masculinity seminar yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait he's
doing he's doing a seminar with these
people
and then he's like you know weakness is
like
he's like you we we are not weak and
then he calls his son out
and then he says you know my son lost a
friend today
who died and then he looks at his son
and goes you are not weak
let it out and then his son starts
crying and yelling and then he hugs him
and then everyone starts like snapping
their fingers and then it shows this
main character's face go like
like shocked as she's secretly watching
from the top of the stairs
and i was watching i'm like wait wait
hold hold on isn't that what they want
wait wait wait wait like hold on a bunch
of guys got together the snapping the
fingers thing was weird
the guy explains that his son lost a
friend clapping but when
you don't want to make it what's like so
it's a guy going like
you're not weak you can let it out and
then he starts crying and he hugs him
i'm like
that's that's pretty that's pretty all
right that seems like a good thing this
seems like emotional mature she freaks
out about it
so anyway duchovny is the guy
yeah awesome yeah so basically he writes
a bunch of books about like
what like being masculine and there's
like a point where she's like reading it
she's like
shocked at it and then he walks and she
drops why would anyone be masculine
who would choose such a thing isn't it
funny though that like if this is truly
a jordan peterson stand-in
like that's the thing like to boil him
down to his worst trait would be the
fact that he doesn't think masculinity's
evil
he's writing books about what
masculinity the reason the reason i say
he's jordan peterson
is because he said you know
something about the order that they
bring or whatever like what he does with
masculinity's order
and that you know jordan peterson is
viewed as this villain by these people
and based on that the general idea i
guess he's like an mra or something
yeah that's masculinity what's mra men's
rights
rights activists in the movies get in
the now
yeah get in there i'm gonna spoil a lot
more aren't you an mri
the movie makes literally no sense
there's no plot that's not a spoiler i
figured
that's why that's why i'm saying it's
it's like how do you spoil something
that's rotten
yeah so it's like boy i love that it's
like watching a bunch of random things
happen in succession that make no sense
and
it really feels like i guess they wanted
gen
x women to have their kids watch it
because like the song
the movie opens with alanis morissette i
think
i love her i can't remember which i love
her from 2001 or whatever
jagged little pill yeah it's it's one of
the songs from jagger
but i was like very obviously they're
trying to cater to
the the women who were young when the
craft one came out you know she wrote
jagged little pill about dave coulier
yeah
no that that's uh you ought to know yeah
the song the most of the album was
inspired by her relationship with dave
but anyway the movie is a bunch of
random garbage that makes no sense
and i got i got to tell you guys i was
triggered
yeah of course no i haven't got
triggered
yeah okay i was literally shaking
because one of the actresses
who plays a trans woman mm-hmm is
cisgendered and
oh no no no judge down but that's true
though that's true
that's horrible so uh in in the movie
randomly and for seemingly no reason
one of the characters just says she's a
trans girl but the actress is actually
cisgendered in real life
i thought that was like not okay
gendered means
your cisgender means comfortable in skin
that's what the uh
love it the the the actress is a
human female and the character she's
playing is a human
transgender female
i thought that was not allowed i'm
pretty sure it isn't it's not i don't
know why they made the exception here
it's funny you mentioned this film being
really pandering and bad
and this is something that i i actually
think is the best part well this is
something i talked about with the
babylon b guys
about like christian films but it also
applies to what you're discussing
is so often people will try to tailor
the media they're producing to a
specific demographic
and they get really heavy-handed with it
but that doesn't work you just have to
make something that you think is good or
funny or whatever you're going for
and if your world view matches up with
your audiences as it should if you've
amassed followers they probably agree
with you about things
then that's just going to come through
you don't you don't you don't have to
put an effort in to represent your
worldview it's just going to come out of
you if you're being honest with the art
that you're producing similar to singing
and
being a musician well think about this
like uh jon stewart was hilarious
yeah right i know i liked john and now
probably the funniest or
one of the funniest political
communities we have is stephen crowder
or david
no yeah freedom tunes is fantastic i
really appreciate it's hilarious i was
kidding
dave chappelle's great but he's not
overtly a political comedian political
comedians
right right right so if you watch any of
the woke brigade stuff john oliver
it's like they're not even telling jokes
yeah exactly when you watch crowder
crowders
is actually funny yeah so
it's like the weirdest thing to me that
this flip is happening where
now when i watch you know internet
cartoons that make jokes it's
you know freedom tunes and then i turn
on like samantha b and i'm like you're
literally not telling me a joke you're
just insulting trump
calling him a pig this is funny because
um i was you wanted to watch my most
recent video today
and while we were sitting down to wash
it the advertisement we got before it
was for trevor noah
yeah i know it was criminally unfunny it
was really really bad
trevor noah and he's on television right
i just have a youtube channel but the
funny thing about trevor
is that his comedy right now is like
youtube videos from 2008.
yeah it's him sitting in his room with a
tv behind him and i'm like dude
even i like we pulled a sheet over some
wood
like what you know what i mean like we
made an effort no this looks good this
is a good looking studio
well we we did do a decent amount of
work in this place but like downstairs
uh and where i do my normal show it's
it's it's not up we're in a different
it's downstairs from where we are
i just put stuff like in the back put a
bookshelf up yeah
and i'm like dude this isn't even that
hard to do like i know
minus the cameras so what's your whole
career like it is
there's no excuse for the how many
months has it been now
seven eight months or whatever of
lockdown they couldn't have been like
you can work from home like you normally
do here's a good camera and a background
yeah really it makes no sense yeah it
just looks it's like really weird and
i'll tell you what
these people live or die by their studio
audience being told to laugh
that's very true because a lot of what
they say
people exactly it's it's jeb bush yeah
jeb energy that's true no laugh tracks
are jeb comedy yeah it's true comedy
please laugh yeah yeah yeah i feel bad
for uh
well i should say i feel bad but there's
so many shows that rely on laugh tracks
i'm not a fan of them well like here's
the thing
with all these comedians who who were
criticizing because we don't think their
work is very good i mean almost all of
them are certainly funny people they
could write good jokes but they have a
writing staff i think oftentimes that
probably
doesn't feel they need to put the effort
in because they're pandering to a
political subsection it's like as long
as i say something they agree with
they'll think that's collector
yeah exactly claptor um whereas i think
if you just like try to put something
out there that's zany and goofy and
funny and makes you laugh but it's about
a political topic again like the angle
you're going to take and what you are
going to find funny
is going to appeal to your audience
without you needing to go overboard to
make it clear
your audience finds you you don't have
to search for an audience exactly you
know you don't just put make stuff that
yeah
just make stuff that's true to yourself
how do you do woke comedy when you can't
make fun of your own side
exactly that's exactly yeah so like i
make fun of conservatives and it's clear
it's clear that i have a a right-leaning
channel and i'm a right-wing person or a
conservative person your dave rubin
video was brutal
thank you yeah i think i'm mentioning
this and i felt bad so when i wrote that
dave rubin video the original idea was
just to
i didn't even think i was going to make
it a cartoon i was just writing the
script out and i was trying to
figure out what impressions i could do
or like trying to write for different
political figures for other videos
it's just an exercise and i was like
well where do i put them what's the
framing device i was like oh well of
course dave rubin's show
and i didn't really have a dave rubins
dave ruben impression but i thought he
pronounced the letter g kind of funny
when he said agree is it guy
agree i just started writing
i would have i just wrote a bunch of
lines that sounded like really over the
top things political personalities would
say and then in between each one just i
agree because it's just an
easy way to write it uh but then i got
progressively more and more ridiculous
it's got like a million views and it's
like something yeah well i so i uploaded
it and
fans some of the fans were like why did
you go so hard on youtube
i was like oh i'm so stupid i literally
i wasn't even trying to rip on him but
um he commented the top comment i i
refreshed the video
uh the day of because i was feeling kind
of bad and the top comment was from the
reuben report and it said i agree
yeah yeah that's that's that's the point
sense of humor he's cool
he was very cool but i've met him and he
and i have actually the video's not done
yet because it's been
this video has been very much on the
back this this video has been very much
on the back burner for like over a year
because i want it to be really good
since dave reuben took the time to voice
act in it i don't want it
to be one of the videos that i just
complete in a week yeah he and i got
together and like recorded a script for
a new video well so
he was very cool about it this is the
point you literally like you when you
did the mccloskey's video
you show him holding the gun backwards
yeah
there's self-awareness on the right
right now to like
being made fun of and knowing why you're
being made fun of that the left doesn't
have any more yeah because we're funny
too and like even if you're right you
can still be ridiculous
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you